if you're starting a new business the
best thing to do to get your first five
customers is to give away the service
for free and don't believe the people
who tell you that you're a special
Snowflake and you should value your time
because let's be real it's not valuable
because you're not good yet because
they're your first five clients and so
what you do get when you get first five
clients is you get people to finally say
yes number two is consider them free
trial clients where you need to keep
serving them at some point when you say
hey I can only do this for money now
they want to pay you to continue to get
the stuff and if they don't then the
only exchange you ask for is that they
give you feedback they give you a review
or a testimonial and if you do a really
good job that they refer a friend